fa freddo e ho la febbre è tornato il
sacco dell'immondizia come vestito è
uscita la nuova mappa ragazzi di player
non batte granché sembra veramente il
paese del narcotraffico e quindi abbiamo
voluto provarla io thomas pietro e fare
schifo come al solito però almeno con
stile
buona visione ma siamo tutti donne
arrivano mi qua qua siamo tutti e tre
donne andiamo da kiko quando abbiamo
visto qui a pietro si è fatto un pochino
più bionda che resta sbattono da quattro
soldi con le mèches ma cretino e il
problema gravissimo che la messa e la
mettiamo fino ai narcotrafficanti fatah
fumo clicca tell them and day
ma al pari ragazzi punti non ora lo rese
il primo ad atterrare ai tipo 1 2 3 4 6
7 persone dietro el primero persona lo
so il mio alter ego sono dietro il
tedesco non entrando nel vostro lontana
dai valori pre di un'arma lo prendo
hajar e cucino uccido ma come sei tu sì
tu mi hai ucciso io ti vedo come nemico
che ci è mancato hs buggata bari da
fuoco amico ucciso articolo
io sono atterrato indietrissimo la capra
piango me perché mi tasca ai maiali
nella tasca hai visto a padre al bene di
cimiez doveva padre al sono qua benedica
i miei peccati padre alle op e kato
padre hanno fatto i capelli bruttissimi
vieni a confessarti pietro arrivo e sei
confessa i tuoi peccati di gravati
confessi per quella volta che mi hai
guardato in piedi sì bene allora sei
assolto dei tuoi peccati solo questo
avevi per me posto così posso così posso
andare colpettino posso darlo no adesso
vai confessati nuovo veloci cui si va
bene state facendo catechismo la sanna e
rosanna cristo signore
vai pietro d'aì tutta aiuta scooby dooby
doo where ecco la grande ma io sono la
pistola di sto sparando una pista da
stupidi hanno preso una volta preso una
volta lo presenta di dove sia la
sinistra
ok tutto a posto ho fatto io esco b2
penso qua io con il passaggio senti
shaggy di samica si vola chi guida non
io vai nones a loro schiavi schede video
l'unico ma stai zitto è da prendere come
sollevato ma quale tizio ma va a cagare
un occhio quali
sono le rush prego prego prego non farà
freddo è mamma mia ragazza mia non ci
fossi io a salvare la situa questa è la
mia batmobile dove stiamo andando
ora quanti prendo st collina bene
arriviamo sediamoci a sanremo perché
questa roba deve spingere sandy a
spingere pietro spicci spingi tom pinces
io ho tirato una granata sinistra sotto
c'è uno c'è gente qua sotto ci aspetta
che scendiamo li vedo quanto vicini
rumorosi non caso aia a era che non
potevo fare niente onesto ribeca sarai
più fortunato ma c'è anche la chicca da
un gratta e vinci
io vorrei andare alla leones andiamo a
fare i combattimenti in città a re leone
guerre duro e rumori molesti cota tra i
capi chando qualcuno forse pietro no è
un tubo che perde aguadulce ma ci sono
altre bibite c'è la senior rogio creando
lontana però i rassegna arosio la
proverei a quando si può fare gli aveva
sparato aica brown che vai kemal eccolo
qua fuori
uno ha preso due volte con la palermo
livello 3 1 ha ucciso due donne
provocato sta ricaricando casco lo
scavalco dove sia qua a destra pensione
eccole qua dietro dietro la casa dietro
a casa la trapani francese d'altra parte
non ho ucciso
ok ok posto perfetto grande l'ora di
arrivare alla meta l'affetto dov'è stato
dove non vedo l'ora
eccola uno è collocato ok e l'altro a
caccia sono lui sta mandando agli amici
quindi seguirà tra segua quella macchina
guarda il mondo della 60 mini da noi un
pensionato una caduta maraga mai
pentirsi ma è diventato bellissimo
mucciaccio cuadrado e muggia cisline
dove no no c'è scritto sulla casa ora
che sotto fece mucciaccio di bala
sarebbe bello che gli amici di sassano
apprende c'è anche la pro magica in
questo macchina figata saprà dove sto
andando a vincere a far prima ce ne
fosse il problema di benzina bella
faccia 746 a
holland ha ucciso nove stima carica
giorno non solo cui attribuisce a 130
anni fa
non voglio che mi faccia aveva fatto
riguardo cava ca ti sta guardando invito
la stazione sua anche la famosa come da
dove dalla roccia money never di tutta
la vostra ditelo dietro da destra e
destra per farcela in fondo che non sta
riuscendo a uccidermi per la roccia
pietroburgo e quindi la estiva di
quest'area la nuova mappa di ma perché
parlo francese messicano il posto vi sia
piaciuto spero che tra la plata il promo
abbiate scelto la plata comunque perché
ho un piombo cromo
vabbè proprietà non so cosa voglia dire
questi casi chi se ne frega non ci
arriva a dieci minuti dicendo cagate il
video è corto fini spero che video vi
sia piaciuto ragazzi come se mi piace
fare questo mi piace anche adesso c'è
questo tanti netscape sono esauriti
scrivetemi ci vediamo in un prossimo
video o una prossima sparatoria paul
allen muciaccia da noi si usa
conquistarne mucciaccia con le
sparatorie infatti pietro essi sempre
single bella ragazza